"HANNITY," BUT I AM GLAD THAT
YOU WERE ON WITH US.
AND WE MENTION THIS EARLIER, THE
FORMER G.O.P. LUMINARY SPEAKING
OUT AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP,
SHALL EVEN BOTHER?
TONIGHT HERE IS THE SAMPLER.
>> IT’S ABOUT A PERSON.
A PERSON DECENT ENOUGH, STABLE
ENOUGH, STRONG ENOUGH TO GET THE
ECONOMY BACK ON TRACK.
DONALD TRUMP ISN’T THAT PERSON,
JOE BIDEN IS.
>> JOE BIDEN ON THE OTHER HAND
HAS A PLAN TO STRENGTHEN THE
ECONOMY FOR WORKING PEOPLE AND
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS.
>> HE IS A REALLY GOOD MAN, HE
IS EXACTLY WHAT THE NATION NEEDS
AT THIS TIME.
>> Laura: IS THAT REALLY THE
NEW FACE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, LOBBYIST AND
BILLIONAIRES?
BUT THOSE SO-CALLED REPUBLICANS
WERE MERELY A WARM-UP ACT FOR
THE MOST INSEPARABLE OF THE
NEVER-TRUMP GENRE.
>> AMERICA IS AT A CROSSROADS,
SOMETIMES ELECTIONS REPRESENT A
REAL CHOICE AND I KNOW THAT
JOE BIDEN WITH HIS EXPERIENCE,
WISDOM, AND DECENCY CAN BRING US
TOGETHER TO HELP US FIND A
BETTER WAY.
THEY FEAR JOE MAY TURN SHARP
LEFT AND LEAVE THEM BEHIND.
I DON’T BELIEVE THAT.
BECAUSE I KNOW THE MEASURE OF
THE MAN IT IS REASONABLE,
FAITHFUL, RESPECTFUL, AND YOU
KNOW, NO ONE PUSHES JOE AROUND.
>> Laura: DID THAT REMIND YOU
OF THIS TWO IN
"THE WIZARD OF OZ"?
I DON’T EVEN KNOW, BUT HERE TO
RESPOND IS TEXAS
SENATOR TED CRUZ.
THERE IS SO MUCH TO SAY AND SO
LITTLE TIME, BUT YOUR RESPONSE
TO JOHN KASICH, THOUGH.
>> WELL, LOOK AT, HE HAS BEEN AN
ANGRY DENIAL FOR FOUR YEARS.
WHAT WE SAW TONIGHT WAS THE
BEGINNING OF THE COLLAPSE OF
JOE BIDEN’S BASEMENT STRATEGY.
HE HAS BEEN HIDING IN HIS
BASEMENT SINCE HE WON THE
NOMINATION, BUT TONIGHT WAS
BERNIE SANDERS’ NIGHT.
TONIGHT, SO JOHN KASICH IS
PROMISING VOTERS, DON’T PAY
ATTENTION TO THE CRAZINESS ON
THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE.
JOE IS NOT THAT CRAZY, YOU KNOW
WHO DID NOT BELIEVE JOHN KASICH?
BERNIE SANDERS DO NOT BELIEVE
JOHN KASICH, HE STOOD UP THERE
AND SAID OUR RADICAL SOCIALIST
AGENDA HAS WON.
WE HAVE TAKEN OVER THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, AND JOE BIDEN
IS OURS.
AND THAT REALLY UNDERSCORES THE
STAKES OF THIS ELECTION.
IF THE DEMOCRATS WIN, YOU ARE
LOOKING AT BERNIE SANDERS AND
ASCENSION, AOC, YOU’RE LOOKING
AT MARK MY WORDS
ELIZABETH WARREN AS TREASURY
SECRETARY.
BERNIE SANDERS MIGHT BE
SECRETARY OF STATE.
THESE ARE RADICALS AND THAT’S
WHERE THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS.
AND I DON’T THINK THAT’S WHERE
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE.
>> Laura: SENATOR, EXCUSE ME,
THE MIDWEST, THINK OF MIDWEST
STATES, RIGHT, DISCUSSING LAST
WEEK IN THE MIDWEST.
I’M NOT GETTING THE STRATEGY.
I’M JUST NOT GETTING AMERICA IS
A HORRIBLE, AWFUL, RACIST
COUNTRY.
WE ARE TERRIBLE, TRUMP IS
ROTTEN, STATUES ARE COMING DOWN
AND WE DON’T CARE, THE RIOTING
WAS NOT MENTIONED AT ALL, THE
DAMAGE MENTIONED OINTMENT DONE
BY THE WRITING, HOW DOES THE
APPEAL REALLY APPEAL IN
JOHN KASICH OHIO IN
PENNSYLVANIA, AND PLACES LIKE
MINNESOTA, WISCONSIN, DOES THIS
REALLY APPEAL?
>> IT DOESN’T, AND THE DEMOCRATS
TODAY ARE THE PARTY OF THE RICH,
THE PARTY OF COASTAL ELITES,
MANHATTAN AND SAN FRANCISCO,
KAMALA HARRIS WAS A BOLD MOVE TO
LOCKDOWN THE VOTE IN
SAN FRANCISCO, AND THAT’S WHO
THEY ARE TRYING TO APPEAL TO IS
THE RADICAL LEFT, WHEN IT COMES
TO WORKING MEN AND WOMEN, WHEN
IT COMES TO UNION MEMBERS, WHEN
IT COMES TO THE OHIO STEEL
WORKER, THEY WERE NOWHERE TO BE
FOUND.
THE DEMOCRATS DON’T HAVE A
MESSAGE FOR TEAMSTERS.
THEY DON’T HAVE A MESSAGE FOR
RIGHT NOW NT FOR MOBS ARE
BURNING POLICE UNION HALLS.
THEY USED TO BE THAT UNION
LEADERS WOULD STAND TOGETHER,
BUT THE DEMOCRATS HAVE SAID, WE
CARE MORE ABOUT THE WOKE MOB
THAN WE DO ABOUT STANDING WITH
COPS OR FIREFIGHTERS OR WORKING
MEN AND WOMEN, AND TO GO TONIGHT
WITHOUT SAYING A MEANINGFUL WORD
ABOUT THE RIOTS AND THE POLICE
OFFICERS BEING MURDERED, IT IS
AN EXAMPLE OF HOW THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THEY ARE
GETTING MORE AND MORE EXTREME.
AND IT’S ALL BECAUSE THEY HATE
DONALD TRUMP.
THAT’S WHAT THEY STAND FOR IS
RADICAL LEFTISM AND HATING
TRUMP.
THAT’S NOT A MAJORITY VISION IN
AMERICA.
>> Laura: AND THEY GO FOR A
HOLLYWOOD CELEBRITY TO BE THE MC
TONIGHT.
I GUESS THEY HOPE EVERYBODY
WATCHING IS A
"DESPERATE HOUSEWIVES"."
THAT THEY ARE JUST GOING TO
THROW IN WITH THE DEMOCRATS,, WE
WILL LOSE THE FREE MARKET AND
POLICE IN THE SUBURBS, BUT WE
REALLY THINK THIS IS A FUN RIDE
TO BE ON.
AGAIN, I DON’T GET IT AND I
DON’T THINK IT PLAYS.
DEMOCRATS ALSO USE THE NIGHT TO
SPREAD AND I HAVE TO GET YOUR
TAKE ON THIS, THIS POST OFFICE
CONSPIRACY TO RIG THE ELECTION,
WATCH.
>> THE U.S. POSTAL SERVICE, IT
IS CENTRAL TO SO MUCH OF OUR
LIVES, VETERANS COUNT ON THE
POST OFFICE TO GET THEIR
PRESCRIPTIONS.
A SOCIAL SECURITY COUNT ON THE
POST OFFICE TO GET THEIR CHECKS.
>> HE IS PUTTING THE LIVES OF
NEVADA SENIORS AT RISK BY TRYING
TO DEFUND THE POST OFFICE.
>> THE PRESIDENT MAY HATE THE
POST OFFICE, BUT HE IS STILL
GOING TO HAVE TO SEND THEM A
CHANGE OF ADDRESS CARD COME
JANUARY.
>> Laura: A MOAT TO MS. LONG
GLORIA AND FRIENDS, THEY STOP
SENDING SOCIAL SECURITY CHECKS
THROUGH THE MAIL IN 2013 UNDER
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
SENATOR CRUZ, FIRST IT WAS
RUSSIA, THEN UKRAINE, AND NOW IT
IS THE POST OFFICE.
A NEW HOAX FOR EVERY TIME AND
EVERY MOMENT.
>> AND THIS ONE IS BIZARRE.
IT IS IMPRESSIVE TO SEE THE
DEMOCRATIC TALKING POINTS THAT
WHEN THEY DECIDE ON A MESSAGE
EVERY SINGLE DEMOCRAT ACROSS THE
COUNTRY REPEATS IT WORD FOR
WORD, BUT TO THE POST OFFICE,
AND WILLING TO THAT NOT A SINGLE
PERSON THEY ARE SPEAKING HAS
BOUGHT A STAMP IN THE LAST FIVE
YEARS.
THEY HAVE NO IDEA WHAT IS GOING
ON WITH THE POST OFFICE.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW WHAT THIS IS
ALL ABOUT.
WHICH IS THE DEMOCRATS ARE
DESPERATE TO BEAT DONALD TRUMP,
AND SO THEY ARE PUSHING FOR THE
SCHEME THAT THEY CALL UNIVERSAL
MAIL-IN VOTING, AND THEY WANT
EVERYONE TO DO IT BECAUSE IT IS
PARTICULARLY SUSCEPTIBLE TO
VOTER FRAUD.
THEY WANT TO ENABLE WHAT THEY
HAVE DONE IN CALIFORNIA WHAT IS
CALLED VOTER HARVESTING.
IN TEXAS WE HAVE TOUGH RULES TO
PROTECT AGAINST VOTER FRAUD IN
TEXAS AND SOME OF THE HISTORY
WAS THAT THEY WERE ADOPTED BY
DEMOCRATIC LEGISLATORS IN TEXAS
BECAUSE THERE WAS A LONG HISTORY
OF SOUTH TEXAS OF VOTER FRAUD IN
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARIES WHERE
UNSCRUPULOUS POLITICAL
OPERATIVES, FOR EXAMPLE THEY
WOULD GO TO A NURSING HOME AND
THEY WOULD GO TO EACH PERSON AND
SAY, HERE, FILL OUT YOUR BALLOT
AND LET ME HELP YOU, JUST CHECK
JOE BIDEN, FILL IN THAT DIET,
AND THEN THEY WOULD COLLECT THEM
AND ALL OF THE ONES GET MAILED,
AND IF SOMEONE WAS STUBBORN OF
ENOUGH TO VOTE TRUMP THAT THEY
JUST THROW THAT IN THE TRASH.
AND TO THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO BE
ABLE TO ENABLE VOTER FRAUD,
THAT’S WHAT THE WHOLE
POST OFFICE NONSENSE IS ABOUT IS
BECAUSE THEY ARE TRYING TO BE IN
A POSITION TO STEAL THE
ELECTION.
IT’S ABOUT THEIR HATRED FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
>> Laura: SENATOR CRUZ, I ALSO
BELIEVE THAT THERE IS A VERY
CYNICAL UNDERCURRENTS INVOLVED
IN ALL OF THIS THAT ALMOST ONCE
TO SEE A BUILDING MOVEMENT
TOWARDS MORE CIVIL UNREST IF
THINGS DON’T GO THEIR WAY,
BECAUSE THEN THEY WILL SAY, YOU
TOOK IT FROM THE MAILBOXES, YOU
STOLE THE MAILBOXES.
IT SEEMS LIKE -- I FIND THIS TO
BE A VERY DANGEROUS TACTIC, THEY
ARE PLAYING WITH FIRE HERE WITH
THESE TYPES OF ALLIES AND ARE
YOU WORRIED ABOUT THAT REALLY
QUICK?
>> LISTEN, YOU’RE EXACTLY RIGHT.
WE HAVE SEEN WHETHER IT IS
REPRESENTATIVE PRESLEY OR OR
EARLIER MAXINE WATERS WHO URGED
PEOPLE TO ENGAGE IN CIVIL
UNREST, ESSENTIALLY ENCOURAGED
THE RIOTERS.
YOU HEADED IN MINNEAPOLIS WHEN
ANTIFA, WHEN MOBS WERE
FIREBOMBING STORES AND POLICE
CARS COMING AT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF MINNESOTA IS
HOLDING UP THE ANTIFA HANDBOOK
AND HIS SON THE MINNEAPOLIS CITY
COUNCILMAN SAYING I STAND WITHIN
TiVo.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY WHEN GIVEN
A CHOICE BETWEEN THE SAFETY AND
SECURITY, OF THE MEN AND WOMEN
IS IN THE COUNTRY VERSUS THE
RADICAL MOB, THEY SAID, WE SIDE
WITH THE MOB.
AND I HAVE TO SAY, I FEEL FOR
THE RESIDENCES OF PLACES LIKE
SEATTLE AND PORTLAND WHERE THE
MOB HAS TAKEN OVER IN THE
DEMOCRATIC POLITICIANS HAVE SAID
TO WITH YOU TO THE MEN AND WOMEN
THEY ARE RESPONSIBLE TO PROTECT,
BECAUSE WE ARE NOT WILLING TO
STAND UP TO THE RADICALS BURNING
THE CITIES DOWN.
THAT’S WHO THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY